we'll begin with a story that no doubt
you've been following all weekend the
historic flood disaster in southeast
texas
is likely to continue for days or even
weeks the news is not good there this
morning
rescue crews worked all night long in
houston pulling stranded people out of
vehicles and homes most of america's
fourth
largest city is now under water radar
shows no end to the rain from tropical
storm harvey which made landfall
as a category 4 hurricane more than 48
hours ago
the newest threat comes from a pair of
flood control reservoirs that started
releasing water
overnight that water is flowing down
buffalo bayou straight into downtown
houston as we speak
norah o'donnell is next to the bayou
just west of downtown nora good morning
to you
good morning and as you can tell it is
raining pretty hard here this morning
and the army corps of engineers says it
had
to let the water out of those reservoirs
essentially to save
downtown because they were filling up
too fast but that water
is heading this way it is actually going
to in this buffalo bayou behind me
it's rising about six inches half a foot
every hour and that's expected to flood
hundreds of homes
adding to the misery here that's the
news this morning
this additional flooding as well as the
rain meaning more
mandatory evacuations so far two deaths
and 14
injuries are directly blamed on the
flooding from harvey
and according to the most recent report
there have been up to 2
000 rescues and there's no way to know
how many people are still stranded by
flood waters
our correspondents are all over this
area following the extent of this
disaster and the emergency response
let's first bring in mark strassman who
is with me here
in downtown houston he's been following
the emergency response
overnight mark good morning good morning
you mentioned the 2000 rescues already
and there's nothing but rain in the
forecast for days
local officials are very blunt about it
they do not have the resources to answer
every call for help
so lots of folks have begun to complain
why weren't they told to get out of
harm's way
while they still could instead of being
stuck asking for help
in america's fourth largest city rescues
continue throughout the night
the rising water is everywhere pushing
into homes
and crippling a metro area packed with
nearly 7 million people
the u.s coast guard plucked the stranded
off rooftops
many of them blindsided by the historic
amount of rain
you know i wish we could send out assets
to a neighborhood and say we're here to
get you out of harm's way but we don't
know which neighborhood to send them to
drone video shows downtown houston
swamped
residential streets flooded with both
water and people
trying to get to safety okay we'll try
to get a boat out here
harris county rescue crews are going
door to door helping as many as they can
we have more boats in the water we have
more high water rescue vehicles now
we've almost doubled our ability to
respond and we will get to you
we have nothing but some people in
houston are still
waiting for help gervaisia onezine told
us she has been stuck in the waters
alongside a 95 year old man since
yesterday morning
we need help out here because it's
starting to rain and thunder again
and we can't take any more rain
overwhelmed rescue crews
are getting help from anyone willing to
lend a hand
good samaritans and boats are banding
together to pull
people from danger we're going to go
hook up to the boat
and we're going to go save some more
lives help some more people
until it's all blow over but harvey is
not expected to blow over
anytime soon what i'm saying to
houstonians
let's be very patient houston's mayor
sylvester turner
is standing by his decision not to order
a mandatory evacuation
he said many people would have been
trapped in a massive
and dangerous traffic jam it was the
right decision in terms of their safety
and all ways we must put the interests
of the city of houston
and houstonians first
houston is mostly flat it is also highly
developed there's simply no place for
all this water to run except into
buildings and homes
very tough challenge very tough
challenges some of the u.s coast guard
officials said last night
the resources don't meet the demand for
help here it's overwhelming it's
overwhelming